[Musique]
nous espérons, je pense, que c'est maintenant qu'avec ces
nouvelles mesures, nous pourrons maîtriser
très rapidement tout ce qui existe, nous
espérons que c'est quelque chose que nous
pourrons désormais garantir qu'il soit mis derrière nous en
tant que ville.  Je suis évidemment très préoccupé
par l'impact sur le
bien-être de la ville, la santé générale
des habitants de la ville, mais aussi par
l'économie de la ville.
[Musique] [
Musique]
nous surveillerons de près le respect des
règles de distanciation sociale.  et nous prendrons d'
autres mesures si cela est nécessaire,
plus les gens suivront les règles,
plus vite nous prendrons le contrôle de ce virus
et ramènerons Lester à la normale,
revenant à la chance, cela pourrait être une
bonne chose pour se débarrasser du virus, mais
rouvrir beaucoup d'endroits à Lester ont
dit que les clients étaient là avant de s'en
sortir la dépression revient à l'université
d'un peu comme la batterie de Mokuba
la façon dont les gens viennent
dans nos rues et tout le reste
expérimentez bien cela ne peut pas arriver il n'y a
pas de social  Je sais à distance que les gens aiment
ne pas trouver de patron n'importe où ou
quelque chose comme pas de potentiel, même
pas dans une police ou quelqu'un comme j'essaierai
d'aller vers les gens, je peux essayer de vous les
Deadlands que les gars, s'il vous plaît, bougez ou tristes
ou quelque chose comme non, gardez le  distance
ou quelque chose comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous